The connection between the virtual and the real one is becoming closer every
day. One aspect that I find particularly exciting is how objects we design in
the virtual world can be made real just a few hours later. Even if you don't own
a 3D printer, you can order 3D printed objects from a business that does. For
example I found this teapot model on the web at Sculpteo, a 3D print service
provider based in France. I previewed it on the website in Web GL, picked out
the material, and ordered it. At that point, there was no physical model, it was
just data on a computer somewhere. A week later, when the real thing arrived
here in California, that honestly amazes me. To learn more about the connection
between 3D graphics and 3D printing. Jessie Harrington Au and I talked about
these topics while at the Autodesk gallery.